you
[Music]
we have a guy on our staff who's the
head of our IT department his name is
Chris Hayes there's a photo of him
great yeah a little confident he's a
great guy very mr. clean I know exactly
he's a great guy as a computer genius
here's the thing whenever I walked by
Chris's desk it's not that far from my
office whenever I walk by his desk he's
almost always eating Taco Bell and I'm
not making that up
he is obsessed with their food yes like
it's like a religion with him yes okay
and it's gone to the point where we make
jokes about it at the office well that
got me wondering if chris loves Taco
Bell so much is there something I can do
for him that won't cost me any money but
give him great joy using the incredible
power I have in show business okay well
I thought about it I came up with a
scheme here's what I did I wanted to do
a nice thing for you because I make
people's dreams come true I'm the TV
host that I know you and that's most
likely Ellen that does you think anymore
Ellen in there okay all right Ellen does
that this is what I did I've taken Chris
here to Taco Bell headquarters in Irvine
California and we are going to give you
the complete Taco Bell experience get in
here again that's harder than I thought
so we're gonna go in right now to the
sleepy little hamlet that is Taco Bell
there it is right there
tiny little Mexican village this is
Katie Gardner hi Katie and your
marketing manager here at Taco Bell yes
you're going to give Chris the full Taco
Bell experience today yeah we have quite
a few superfans so we have kind of an
experience that we like to save for all
of you special when you say super fans
defined super fans how many times a week
does someone have to eat Taco Bell to be
considered a super fan I would say at
least twice a week twice a week he's I
think every two he's three to four he's
got that if you want to take it to the
next level though you have to get a
tattoo so they're people that have a
taco there are several people that have
talked about tattoos would you get a
Taco Bell tattoo
Mike Tyson tattooed his face yes would
you be willing to have a Taco Bell
tattoo on your face my face what if it
meant free Taco Bell the rest of your
life
we're here in the Taco Bell Museum what
are we looking at here Katie here you
are looking at a brick from one of the
very first Taco Bell's in San Bruno oh
thank god I thought that was the first
experimental taco it did not go well I
have a crunch rep at least once a week
they also have a breakfast crunch wrap
what is how was that different okay so
and will you look at me when you tell me
about it
yeah please okay go okay we're gonna
play a little romantic music what
rattled eggs some thanks three cheese
blend sausage creamy jalapeno sauce all
wrapped up in a tortilla
my wife today
I'll follow you to the interview you can
also put a setup on the light inside of
it
don't say that so we are actually
outside of the sensory panel this is
where we have employees come and they
test our food I love this place you have
a job ok how are you enjoying that
sandwich do you mind if we film that
sure ok I'm not gonna be creepy about it
but this oh my god ok ok ok ok
I'm gonna drizzle that on all right oh
well you could do you never hire someone
to watch the people as they're eating
the food yeah I could do that well let's
go do that I'm doing it now so these are
people coming in to do some testings
right now yeah sitting down and that's
that's which window is she had 6
like maybe even smaller right now
I'm Missy Missy you run the innovation
kitchen I do today this is a new never
before tried Casey lupa this is not even
available to the public yet correct
we're getting a chance to try this out
okay here we go
I do it makes sense okay it's a little
like case of lupus
I disagree about that case of lupus
blood disease new treatment well time
for my first experimental bite let's do
it
[Laughter]
[Applause]
good mind if I have another sip of my
clown wig are you ready for dessert
dessert yes
so these cinnamon twists are pretty
classic to Taco Bell the crunchy so
cinnamon twists are pretty classic to
Taco Bell they've been around for a long
time in your face so I'm sorry you said
this is a DNA strand that you guys
deep-fried and then shot out of a
cinnamon cannon is that right there's
Leanna am i eating right now could we do
more absolutely I'd love to invite you
to make some of your own menu items
there's one thing we know about me it's
that I'm a very good Mexican chef I have
a lot of ideas and it thinks it'll quite
good for example you guys are obsessed
with taco shells quesadillas as a food
delivery system what you're overlooking
is one of the most time-honored food
delivery systems around the ice cream
cone
[Applause]
[Music]
this is the wave of the future for Taco
Bell Chris do you like the burrito
supreme yes have you ever tried to eat
one while you were driving yes hard to
do isn't it yes okay I've got the
solution you start selling these what
people use to play harmonicas oh and
it's a burrito delivery system today I'm
going to give to you my invention for
Taco Bell the Irish taco it's called the
Oh taco cabbage mashed potatoes on beef
and lots of corn D and then my own
special sauce
the guerrilla please
[Music]
well another fast-food chain where I'm
no longer welcome but I do want to thank
you guys at Taco Bell are you happy now
I'm extremely happy ok it's been a good
day you're fired
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you